musicalarue c'est un sentiment de
liberté d'amour et de paix dans la
région on n'a pas trop de chanteurs qui
viennent
non non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
m
elle
[Musique]
non
se retrouver la scène c'est comme si on
était privé du pas de manger à peu près
il a maintenant on peut manger comme la
seule sais c'est qu'il fait vivre
[Musique]
et
oh
de retour sur scène vous avez peur ne
pas avoir les repères ça fait vraiment
bizarre de voir des gens de les entendre
chanter les chansons de voir des gens
heureux rien que voir des gens heureux
des enfants danser
[Musique]
m
ma santé on habitue avant tout à fait un
angola donc ça va et après le nombre de
gens ça vraiment bizarre parce qu'un
festival semble et pas beaucoup de gens
mais c'est pas un festival vraiment les
mesures c'est c'est peut-être strict
mais en tout cas si on veut passer à un
moment en tout
tranquillité je pense que c'est
nécessaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
débat